and we don't have another [ __ ] texas
or florida fiasco on our hands with a
bunch of [ __ ] trump lackeys running
those states
like in florida and texas we do not need
trump lackeys running these [ __ ]
states
we see what he did to our country we do
not need to systematically do this to
our states one by one so go vote
virginia go [ __ ] vote
go [ __ ] vote and stay pissed
even after this election it's not over
we got elections next year we have to
stay pissed we have to stay engaged we
have to stay active
speaking of staying staying engaged and
active apparently jfk juniors is either
still alive
or
he's going gonna be resurrected from the
dead or i'm not sure what the [ __ ] is
going on
i i cannot tell you how this q and on
[ __ ]
it just it just baffles me
it baffles my mind
um you know i say here all the time that
we are at the intersection of
wrestlemania in real life i actually
believe that's what this is at the heart
of it this q anon stuff
is like professional wrestling to some
of these people now i don't have
anything against professional wrestling
i don't have against people watching
professional wrestling it's it's
probably pretty good entertainment i
haven't watched it in a long time
because i'm i
you know i grew kind of away from the
professional wrestling thing but have
you ever have you ever have a
conversation with someone who is a not
only a professional wrestling fan
but thinks that somehow this this stuff
is is real or wants it to be real have
you ever had a conversation with someone
who truly wants professional wrestling
to be real they can't just come to grips
with this is all it's all [ __ ]
staged it's all fake
it's and
and again these are real athletes
they're doing real athletic things they
actually get injured
you know they're they're doing the moves
but they're not they're not they're not
actually fighting they're not actually
feuding they're not it's all it's all a
show it's entertainment folks it's
entertainment the bad guys aren't the
bad guys the good guys aren't the good
guys that's not how it works it it's
it's all show
it's all for you to stay engaged and
there's nothing wrong with that it's
entertainment it's like reality tv if
you guys think reality tv is real you
are
you are way outside your [ __ ] you way
outside your [ __ ] mind
reality tv isn't real
a really good popular one is like house
hunters a lot of people like health
hunters that [ __ ] is fake
that shit's fake they already have the
house bought like they already bought
the house that they're gonna that that's
bought
so the the fiasco of them going to three
different houses a lot of times those
houses aren't even for sale it's fake
it's [ __ ] fake but it's fake for the
sake of entertainment just like
wrestling
well here's what's happened there's a
lot of there's a lot of [ __ ] people
that want professional wrestling to be
real you know this is the education
problem that we have in this country
is education is we've we've failed at
this
we have [ __ ] failed miserably at
education obviously um but they want
professional wrestling to be real like
they want it to be real
so
so what happens is is because they want
it to be real they believe all kinds of
weird [ __ ] right
and that that the foe that the heel and
the the hero and all this [ __ ]
and they get involved in these story
lines and even though when you look at
it on its face you're like jesus christ
not only is this fake but they're not
even attempting like the wwe isn't even
attempting to make a play for that this
could be real
this is the same thing i think that's
going on with q anon i think what has
happened
is a lot of people have been able to uh
uh follow these
these
half brain
weird ass [ __ ] story lines on their
on their facebook ivermecton institute
groups
and and uncle ned you know spreads
around this this this q anon stuff and
it's pretty dangerous because they're
getting these people to believe this
stuff let me show you a picture here i
gotta find it there you go
um
here is a picture let's give some credit
here since we're showing pictures um
this is a picture down in dallas uh
steven writes there is currently a large
crowd of what appears to be q anon
believers at the att discovery plaza in
downtown dallas a popular q a on theory
recently
is that jfk jr the son of john f kennedy
the president of the kennedy family
would be making a big
announcement now
at daley dally daley plaza by the grassy
knoll sometime tomorrow so that's that's
sometime today because this was last
night last night
this was last night so what what
what stephen is reporting here
is that there are a bunch of [ __ ] q
and honors down in downtown dallas
gathering
obviously talking about how jfk jr the
son
the son of the president
john f kennedy
okay
the son of jack kennedy
is going to make an announcement at
daley plaza on the grassy knoll
today sometime who knows
but look at these [ __ ] pictures here
these people are wearing q shirts
there's this guy here if you see my
mouse there's a guy here with a q shirt
on um they've got a bunch of cueing on
uh trump this lady here in the front
she's got a trump shirt on
uh these are trump sorter supporters
these are mega
these are uh
evangelical trump and fools
and you see them gathering and there's
you know tens of them
um but this other picture really defines
it really good
see if i can zoom in here
you see you see the trump guys he's
standing here
and and it says on it kennedy jfk junior
like trump jfk jr 2024
these [ __ ] people
either believe and i'm not sure which it
is
they either believe
that jfk junior is still alive and never
never got in a plane crash
or that he's being come back from the
dead or something
now my assumption is is that they you
know that they could believe in
resurrection like
of course these people would believe
that type of [ __ ] i mean they they they
go and and believe that kind of voodoo
about another particular book
on a weekly basis
which they
completely botch and they completely
take out the stuff that they want
and and leave aside the stuff you know
about you know helping the poor and you
know the [ __ ] that jesus actually did
you know what would jesus do type stuff
[Music]
but they they totally take out the stuff
that they want which is almost nothing
and they bastardized that story so why
wouldn't they bastardize the jfk junior
story because apparently
i mean some people believe like hillary
clinton and the clintons killed jfk
junior but i i guess this q and on stuff
they believe that somehow
jfk jr has been working with trump the
whole time
um
and trying to trying to stave off the
blood sucking child cabal or
i don't know
it's tough to know what the [ __ ] these
people believe
i mean here you have a bunch of [ __ ]
white people
gathering down in dallas thinking that
jfk junior is going to come out tomorrow
on the grassy knoll
and make some sort of announcement
announcement about what
what that he's going to run for for vice
president with trump or that i don't
know why why on daily plaza anyways
are these people like making the
assumption that somehow the death of his
father the president john f kennedy jr
when he was shot and killed
uh in dallas
are they making the assumption that
somehow th this has to do with like
somehow it has to do with trump like
they really are making conspiracy theory
soup here and we've seen it all year
this year um even back like in march you
remember back in march they were they
said that uh trump there was gonna be
the the real inauguration and he was
gonna be the 19th president of the
united states uh because there was an
action that was unlawful to make the the
united states a corporation and
they went by maritime law all this
garbage they what what that is
is that sovereign citizen conspiracy
theory type stuff
crossing over with this q anon and the
the big lie and the trump humping [ __ ]
like that they're crossing and and
intertwining
all these conspiracy theories uh as one
worldly new world order conspiracy
theory is what it seems like to me
and this is where we're at the the
intersection of wrestlemania in real
life on one corner we have the
ivermectin institute and the other
corner we have jfk going to resurrect
from the dead and give a speech
on how his father was shot and killed
a daily pla i don't know or who was on
the grassy no maybe it was him on the
grassy knoll i don't know
i i i'm just [ __ ] tossing around
ideas here to try to figure out what the
[ __ ] these people believe this is
absolute crazy ass nonsense now here's
the troublesome thing about this
is if you look at a lot of people in
this crowd
and you go back and you look at the
trump rallies and you look at the crowd
behind him because it's always the same
[ __ ] have you ever noticed that
it's always the exact
same [ __ ] behind him they just
kind of
shuffle him a little bit it's the same
[ __ ] behind him every single
time they'll put in a few locals you
know so it looks a little different but
it's always the same [ __ ]
behind go look at it i'm dead serious go
look at pictures from rally to rally to
rally and compare the people that are
standing behind trump on the bleachers
because that's almost the only people
that are at the rally in the first place
is you know they got to fill the
bleachers behind him to make it look
like there's a lot of people there and
then they fill the first five rows of
chairs you know to make it look like
there's a lot of people at these places
where he speaks
it's the same [ __ ]
go look at those faces and then look at
these faces in these [ __ ] pictures
go look at them
go see maybe if you can compare them
and see how many of them are the same
[ __ ]
it's it's this that's the biggest fraud
the biggest fraud of this son of a [ __ ]
is that these people love him yeah he's
got his groupies
that show up at all these rallies but
it's the same [ __ ] it's the
same
mother [ __ ] the exact same
[ __ ]
the same tens of people who show up at
his rallies
right here standing in dallas thinking
jfk and i'm sure a few of these people
are down here just to [ __ ] gawk at
the [ __ ] wackadoos right
like who would who wouldn't want to go
to the nut house for some entertainment
down here i mean god damn if you if you
found out if i found out
that uh the the q a niners were coming
to my city and were hoping that jfk
junior was gonna speak i'm like oh god i
gotta go see that
i gotta go [ __ ] see what these people
who who are these people where the [ __ ]
did they come from
what planet are they from
that's what i would want to do so i'm
sure a lot of these people are just down
there gawking
gawking at the cue and hunters they're
not actually q and rs they're just
gawking them like these people are
[ __ ] nuts
and i want to know where's uh walters
probably walter masterson is probably
down here so are the good liars
speaking the good liars there's actually
a good video in the the election
and i'll try to get to it today because
that is an incredible
um piece of content it's just one little
snippet they talk to one guy
but it really it really does give you a
sense of what these q anon
people
believe about this [ __ ] [ __ ] about
about jfk junior and all it's just it's
just it's just gives you a [ __ ]
headache to try to put this all together
in in a in a decent way uh this this
schooly here says whoever threw the jfk
junior piece into the q stew was a
genius
absolutely
[Laughter]
oh it's fantastic i can't i can't even
imagine
the person coming up with this q and on
stuff they're like hmm
what what where's the limit like where
is the line
let's see what's bad company say here we
took jfk jr you can have him back he
keeps babbling about q what is a q
[Laughter]
so maybe that's the theory maybe bad is
bad is indicating here that that
that jfk jr
is was abducted by aliens and that's how
he's gonna come back i i seriously don't
know
i don't know i haven't gotten on the
deep darks part of the web to understand
every single thing about the the q anon
theory i know that
um
the the
the gqp
has bought into this this [ __ ]
jfk junior what i'd like to know what
i'd like to know
is
does does trump believe that he's going
to run with jfk jr like because you know
he's a q a honor right
trump's a cue an honor like and he
believes this and the reason why is
because it talks the q anon stuff talks
a lot about him so that's why he likes
it that's why he believes it is because
it says stuff about him you know that in
his security briefings like his national
security briefings he couldn't keep his
eyes on the page he couldn't keep his
eyes on the piece of paper unless it had
his name on it
so obviously he loves this q and on
stuff so i'm sure he's always on the
deep dark parts of the web reading about
this q and on stuff because it talks
about him as long as it has his name in
it he's able to read other than he's not
uh mike rothschild says a big day
tomorrow
jfk junior's back
trump reinstatement and
uh uh
res
resignation uh new vice president
michael flynn oh and trump becoming god
rest up so let's read this message here
from whiplash three four seven
negative four eight channel
it's a forwarded message let's read i'm
sure this is great insight
if not just insight into what the jfk
junior plot is here trump reinstated
as the 19th president calls up a new
vice president john f kennedy jr okay so
so whiplash here
whiplash three four seven
oh my god
that you you can't
this is this is [ __ ] that you're seeing
here
on the shitless roundup and this is the
[ __ ] list here for sure
so president trump is reinstated as the
19th president you got that that's the
whole sovereign citizen the country did
something unlawful to make itself a
corporation which is not the truth it's
not what happened they just it's in that
it just has anyways
call up a new vice president jfk jr
as
as everything from 1871 was illegal and
unconstitutional so this is where
they're talking about
where in 1871
where the amendment was signed and it
has the word corporation in it and they
get the word corporation really confused
because
they don't have law degrees and don't
understand what the legal word in that
amendment of corporation is they think
the government was formed as
accompaniers i don't know some [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] that's why they believe
they're sovereign citizens and don't
have to pay taxes and all kinds of
craziness that they're not actually
citizens of the united states because
the united states actually in the
country it's a company it's a it's a
corporation is that's what these
sovereign citizens believe go go [ __ ]
look it up if you want to look it up it
ain't worth it it ain't worth it but you
know
but it says was illegal and
unconstitutional justice thomas the only
supreme court justice remaining so
apparently he is the only i don't know
why justice thomas will be the only one
but i i guess q will deem him maybe john
f kennedy jr
uh i don't know uh trump will step down
oh here we go so mangle
mango mussolini jesus
does the right thing and steps down for
john f kennedy jr who is a democrat by
the way uh will become president he
would
he was a democrat
he was a liberal
john f kennedy jr will become president
like he would if he wasn't for hillary
plotting to kill him so here's the
hillary clinton
uh part of it and then he will call up
general flynn mike flynn the traitor
mike flynn as his vice president so now
we go from trump being the 19th
president
to him stepping aside and letting
the corpse of john f kennedy jr becoming
president because justice thomas
obviously is the only supreme court
justice which makes john f kennedy alive
and being able to be president because
trump steps aside because trump totally
would give up power here i mean that's
totally believable all this stuff
oh [ __ ] i wish these people i wish these
people would write books and make movies
because these movies would be
absolutely [ __ ] bombs um so so john f
kennedy jr becomes the president
uh like he would have if he wasn't for
killery plotting to kill him because i
guess hillary tried to plot to kill him
so he had to act like he was dead or i
don't know and then general mike flynn
becomes his vice president trump will be
become one of the seven new kings oh
trump's a king are you listening people
are you hearing what's gonna happen
today this is all supposed to happen
today by the way
all this is supposed to happen today
trump will become one of the seven new
kings
most likely the king of kings
what the [ __ ]
oh son of a [ __ ]
seven trumpets seven presidential
messages to all phones on earth seven
kingdoms
what in the actual [ __ ] does that [ __ ]
mean you know the craziest the [ __ ]
craziest part about this is you see this
little eye down here this indicates
that that 24 000
people
saw this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and probably believed it
jesus [ __ ] christ
let's give mike some credit here on the
[ __ ] list roundup thanks mike for your
tweet
on
the [ __ ] list round up the [ __ ] list
maybe i should do that after um
every uh
every tweet i give credit for all right
step up uh let's get out of crazy land
let's get out of [ __ ] crazy land
which
we go right back in the crazy land here
you see under the for you tab that's
trending let's go brent brendan brandon
not brandon brandon d-e-n i guess
because the they're suggesting that
twitter has censored the hashtag let's
go brandon
because it's offensive i actually i
actually would rather than just say [ __ ]
joe biden wouldn't you you bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] just say